ce nouveau variant on dit on dit qu'il
est méchant pourquoi parce que il
échappe à l'immunité et qu'il est plus
contagieux que les autres variants mais
comme j'avais dit sur ce plateau il y a
quelques mois je pense très sincèrement
que le pire est derrière nous et que on
a jamais vraiment il fait vraiment on
n'est pas dans la même dans les mêmes
circonstances que la première vague
pourquoi parce que on a acquis une
immunité qui a eu les vaccins que des
gens ont été malades et que il y a des
moyens de se protéger le nouveau variant
il paraît que mine de rien quand tu
l'attrapes ton chi des Bulgarie
qui est un dérivé de ouiq A1 dérivé du
bs5 lui-même sous variance de de l'eau
micros et il est donc plus contagieux
mais on n'est pas plus méchant que la
souche
moi j'ai des gars qui l'ont eu ils m'ont
dit sur la tête de ma mère ils m'ont dit
ils ont pas pu se lever du ils avaient
eu le premier covid ils ont le deuxième
ils ont le quatrième ils ont une
septième et 9h
non mais je te dis ils sont ils sont pas
morts ils sont pas morts
que des mauvaises nouvelles
ça fait deux ans ils sont là ils sont
super fusion
au bout d'un jour BIM hôpital ça fait
deux ans il m'a envoyé la photo comme ça
faire comme ça ça fait 2 ans qu'on a ce
covid on a quand même
une certaine humilité il y a une unité
de groupe qui est arrivé ils étaient là
oui c'est vacciné bien sûr il y a même
des gens qui ont été vaccinés 4 fois qui
l'ont attrapé non mais
par exemple il faut savoir que il y a un
nouveau vaccin les gens le savent pas
c'est le vaccin bivalent combien
couscous
sur ma vie c'est mon bras frère sur la
tête de ma mère complètement obligé
Cyril on est obligé de suivre les
variants et il y a un nouveau vaccin qui
est actif contre les variants au micro
qui sont responsables pour l'instant de
la plupart des contaminations et il est
actif aussi contre le nouveau variant et
donc j'engage pour faire encore un ah
oui j'engage les gens ils sont qui ont
plus de 60 ans
qui ont plus les gens qui ont plus de 60
ans les amis
on parle de vous et oui et les gens qui
ont des comorbidités
le nom je me souviens plus
mais en tout cas en tout cas avant les
fêtes s'il vous plaît faites-vous
vacciner
quand vous êtes à risque entre les
crises de foi parce que moi je mange
beaucoup de chocolat ça marche pas ça
marche pas
une palette de vaccins
il faut se faire vacciner avant le 10
décembre ce qu'on peut faire le vaccin
pour la grippe contre la grippe et le
vaccin en même temps on peut tout faire
dans une épaule là dans l'autre épaule
l'autre
[Applaudissements]
de strepsilts
je suis une bête et donc donc vraiment
on est on n'est pas dans la même
situation que lors de mes premières
vagues vraiment
je suis malade
[Applaudissements]
quand on est une bête physiquement
est-ce qu'on a moins de chance de d'être
touché
difficilement par le covid je suis une
bête
si vous êtes une bête et si vous êtes
chez monstreux
[Rires]
il faut savoir il faut savoir qu'il y a
un traitement contre le covid et que si
on est fragile pas
il faut lui faire du packs le vide il
faut lui faire du pack Flo vide
c'est le médicament qui n'est pas assez
utilisé en France contre le virus contre
le coronavirus et qui évite les formes
graves si les prix dans les cinq jours
qui suivent la contamination
donc on passe le vaccin de nouveau plus
le pack le pack covidia il est livré
avec de la bière ou pas
pour savoir mais du coup à quoi sert de
vaccin docteur attendez laissez passer
le vaccin ça limite les formes graves
mais si néanmoins vous êtes fragile à
risque et que vous attrapez le covid
même vacciné et bien le Pax le vide
évite que vous fassiez une forme grave
donc le vaccin est efficace
donc en fait il y a une petite
contradiction vous dites qu'il faut que
les gens se faire vacciner pour éviter
les formes graves et après vous dites
mais ces gens à risque vont devoir
prendre un trait sur les millions de
gens il y en a qui passent
au travers de la vaccination on n'est
pas tous ces grands on n'est pas tous
égaux je vous invite est-ce que si on a
l'ancien vaccin comme c'est mon cas en
revanche on est protégé des formes
graves contre ce nouveau covid où il
faut faire ce nouveau question
très bonne question si vous avez été
vacciné il y a plus de six mois et bien
il faut vous refaire vacciner avec le
nouveau avec le nouveau qui en plus de
préférence donc en fait c'est tous les
Français
que c'est pas la vérité de se faire
vacciner tous les six mois c'est le
corps il le supporte bien non mais la
grippe on se fait vacciner tous les ans
je me suis pas fait non non mais on sait
jamais tous les ans non mais clairement
clairement il y a duré un jour mais les
bénéfices risques comme on dit sont très
en faveur du vaccin vraiment pour les
gens à risque je suis mythique
même si vous n'êtes pas risque vous
pouvez non mais vous pouvez faire des
formes graves
les données de la DR ees disent que en
dessous de 60 ans la mortalité de 0 le
taux de létalité de zéro il y a des
sous-vêtements
[Applaudissements]
vigilant ensemble et je lance un appel
solennel respectons les gestes barrières
portons le masque dès que nous sommes
avec des personnes fragiles ou dans des
zones de promiscuité comme les
transports en commun ce sont des petits
gestes qui sauvent des vies nous le
savons ils sont décisifs pour faire
reculer l'épidémie les Français ont
toujours répondu à l'appel de la
responsabilité je n'ai aucun doute qu'il
le feront de nouveau à mon avis la
première ministre elle a dit qu'on
allait remettre au masque
elle recommande et moi la question que
je voulais vous poser c'est s'il
recommande c'est qu'ils sentent
l'inquiétude pourquoi est-ce que
dans ces cas-là il n'impose pas le mât
dans les transports en commun parce que
c'est très dur de l'imposer qu'on a vécu
deux ans avec le masque et que les gens
n'ont ras-le-bol assez de porter le
masque alors il faut dire par contre les
gens à risque les gens à risque les gens
qui ont peur de compagnie de contaminer
d'autres gens à risque doivent porter le
masque il faut être raisonnable doivent
porter le FFP2 parce que dans le métro
même quand le masque était obligatoire
il y avait un certain nombre de
personnes qui ne le mettaient pas et il
suffit de deux personnes qui ne le
mettent pas pour risquer aborder d'être
contaminés donc il faut mettre le FFP2
qui vous protège à 98% voilà de la
contamination voilà voilà alors il y a
Gunther qui est pas content parce que on
va pas saganache
avant il y avait les anciens vaccins les
nouveaux vaccins maintenant il y a le
traitement en fait au bout d'un moment
si le laboratoire ils ont juste envie de
prendre de l'oseille qui propose
directement un abonnement à vie plutôt
nous demander des vaccins à chaque fois
sans dire ridicule et moi ce qui
m'énerve c'est que les chiffres du covid
je les suis de loin mais depuis des mois
j'ai l'impression que c'est toujours les
mêmes mais que les gens qui en parlent
en parlent que quand ça les arrange
c'est quand il y avait la guerre en
Ukraine il y avait pas de covid quand il
y avait les élections il y a pas de
covid et là on nous sort ça du chapeau
comment espèce de marronnier pour faire
peur aux gens c'est confortable je vois
pas que ce soit pour faire peur aux gens
c'est qu'il y a des chiffres c'est que
le R0 qui est le témoin de de de la
progression de l'épidémie est repassée
au-dessus de 1 c'est à dire qu'une
personne contamine plus d'une personne
et que l'épidémie repartie que le taux
d'incidence est très élevé et que quand
même hier il y a eu près de 100000
nouvelles contaminations qui a toussé
c'est moi
chefs
publics ont peur c'est de la submersion
du système de santé vous savez tous que
l'hôpital est en mauvaise posture que il
y a il y a moins de médecins il y a
moins d'infirmiers qui a eu une
hémorragie de gens qui sont partis parce
qu'ils ne se sentaient plus bien à
l'hôpital et ils ont peur de ça donc ils
voudraient qui est pas la conjonction de
trois épidémies la bronchiolite la
grippe et le
covidal au lieu de masquer les gens qui
vous a donné la parole c'est un
américain
britannique si vous voulez en
franco-britannique mes études bon en
tout cas on va suivre tout ça très près
et demain on fera aussi un gros dossier
parce que moi je vous lis ce nouveau
covid me fait peur ce nouveau variant
vous avez jamais été inquiet c'est la
première fois j'ai vu l'état de copains
à moi alors les copains c'est pas des
bêtes comme moi
un jour la grippe un jour la grippe
voilà
écoute-moi bien ici tu seras pas la
bienvenue elle est partie comme une
merde non mais j'ai eu des copains en
très bonne santé
vacciné tu en as un covid très très dur
tout à fait refusion est outil oui mais
je dis pas non
c'est pareil
merci en tout cas à la Régie qui sont à
fond sur le dossier
en tout cas docteur merci d'avoir été
avec vous êtes excellent comme à chaque
fois merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]